>> HIS OWN SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AND IS ADMITTING THAT
WE'RE BEGINNING TO HAVE UP TO
15,000 PEOPLE COMING IN
ILLEGALLY A DAY.
>> I THINK IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
PLAN, THEY NEED TO WAIT TO END.
>> A NATION NEEDS BORDERS.
THOSE BORDERS SHOULD BE SECURE.
AT THE SAME TIME THE, WE NEED
SOME ORDERLY PROCESS FOR
IMMIGRATION.
MARIA: ALARMS ARE SOUNDING FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE NOW AS A
KEY DEADLINE ARE APPROACHES THIS
UPCOMING WEEK.
TITLE 42 WILL EXPIRE AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER ON WEDNESDAY OF
THIS WEEK.
BORDER AGENTS EXPECT THE NUMBER
OF ILLEGAL CROSSINGS TO GO FROM
8,000 A DAY CURRENTLY, 7-8,000
TO 18,000 A DAY TO SURGE INTO
AMERICA AFTER WEDNESDAY.
THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL 6.5 MILLION
PEOPLE A YEAR AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
REFUSES TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
DANGEROUS IMPACT HIS POLICIES
HAVE HAD ON AMERICAN FAMILIES.
LAST FISCAL YEAR BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ENCOUNTERED A RECORD
NEARLY 2.4 MILLION MIGRANTS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER WITH UP TO 1
MILLION GOTAWAYS WHO HAVE EVADED
APPREHENSION ON JOE BIDEN'S
WATCH.
SO THAT'S 5 MILLION PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY CROSSING ON JOE
BIDEN'S WATCH AND ANOTHER 6.5
MILLION EXPECTED OVER THE NEXT
YEAR.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS TEXAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK
AND NATIONAL BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL PRESIDENT BRANDON JUDD.
GENTLEMEN,ST GREAT TO HAVE YOU
HERE TODAY -- IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
I WANT TO GET BOTH OF YOUR TAKES
ON WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TODAY ON
THE GROUND AND HOW YOU'RE
EXPECTING THINGS TO CHANGE COME
WEDNESDAY.
KICK US OFF, DAN PATRICK.
>> WELL, YOU GAVE GREAT NUMBERS,
MARIA, AND BRANDON KNOWS WHAT
EVERY PERSON IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
KNOWS.
WE AP REHEND 2 THE MILLION A
YEAR -- APPREHEND, MAYBE WE
APPREHEND 1 OUT OF EVERY 2 OR 3
THAT ACTUALLY COST.
SO NOW YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT 6
MILLION A YEAR PLUS THE
GOTAWAYS, THAT'S 20-25 MILLION
PEOPLE COMING HERE ILLEGALLY.
MANY ARE COMING FOR JOBS, BUT
NIXED IN WITH THEM ARE
TERRORISTS WE'VE CAUGHT,
CRIMINALS WE'VE CAUGHT.
FENTANYL HAS COME IN BY THE
THOUSANDS OF POUNDS.
THE NUMBER ONE KILLER OF PEOPLE
18 TO 45 IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO WHEN I HEAR THE DEMOCRATS SAY
THEIR OWN PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE
A PLAN, ACTUALLY, HE DOES HAVE A
PLAN.
HE'S ALLOWING AMERICA TO BE
INVADED.
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS THOUGHT
THAT NO PRESIDENT WOULD ALLOW US
TO BE INSAIDED, BUT THEY SAW AN
INVASION AS AN ARMY WITH A GUN.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT TYPE.
INTENDED ONE DAY IN THE NEXT
15-20 DAYS TO BECOME CITIZENS
AND VOTERS SO THE DEMOCRATS, IN
THEIR VIEW, HAVE A LOCK ON THIS
COUNTRY FOREVER AS A ONE-PARTY
SYSTEM.
IT'S A DANGER TODAY ON THE
STREET WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE
COMING HERE UP OUT OF MANHOLE
COVERS THAT WE NOW HEAR FROM EL
PASO WHERE THE MAYOR'S DECLARED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES, OR IT'S UP
COUNTRY IN THIS -- PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY BEING HARMED BY
THESE PEOPLE COMING HERE
ILLEGALLY.
THE REAL DAMAGE IS TO OUR
DEMOCRACY AND TO OUR
CONSTITUTION IN THE LONG TERM
THE.
>> YEAH.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT AN INVASION,
ALTHOUGH THIS MIGHT NOT BE AN
ARMY, IT IS STILL BEING
ORCHESTRATED BY A ORGANIZED
GROUP --
>> YES.
>> IT'S BEING ORCHESTRATED BY
THE CARTELS.
THEY'RE ORCHESTRATING EVERYTHING
THAT WE'RE SEEING ON THE BORDER
SO, YES, I ABSOLUTELY DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS AN INVEGAS, AND I
DO BELIEVE -- INVASION, AND I DO
BELIEVE WE CAN DECLARE IT AS
SUCH.
YOU SHOWED SOME STAGGERING
FIGURES RIGHT NOW.
YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS.
IF WE CONSIDERED EFFORT BEING
JUDGED ON SUCCESS, THEN CARTELS
ARE WORKING EXTREMELY HARD AT
THEIR CRAFT WHILE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARE DOING
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING, THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
BUT EFFORT IS JUDGED ON LYING
AND DEFLECTION, THEN THE WHITE
HOUSE IS GETTING AN AN J +.
THAT'S WHAT -- A+.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE TRUTH,
ABOUT THE FACTS.
THEY DON'T CARE THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY ADDED TO OUR POPULATION
JUST SINCE HE HAS BEEN IN OFFICE
4 MILLION PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE
WE'VE RELEASED INTO THE UNITED
STATES AND THE GOTAWAYS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CROSSINGS,
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES,
AND THAT'S THE MAGNET THAT IS
DRIVING PEOPLE TO CROSS OUR
BORDERS.
AND THAT'S HOW THE CARTELS ARE
MAKING SO MUCH MONEY.
THEY'RE GOING THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD AND ADVERTISING THEIR
SERVICES SAYING ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS GIVE US THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS, WE'LL GET YOU TO THE
BORDER, AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
RELEASE YOU.
WE CAN EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS BECAUSE THERE ARE NO PLANS,
OPERATIONS OR PROGRAMS IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW TO DEAL WITH WHAT'S
EXPECTED.
MARIA: THIS IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY.
AND YOU MENTIONED, BRANDON, THE
CARTELS.
I WENT TO THE BORDER FIVE TIMES.
SOME OF THOSE TIMES I WENT
EMBEDDED WITH YOU AND YOUR TEAM,
AND I WATCHED IT UP CLOSE
FIRSTHAND.
YOU JUST MENTIONED THE CARTELS.
ARE THEY MAKING $300 MILLION AT
LEAST A WEEK AS I WAS TOLD A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO JUST ON
HUMAN SMUGGLING?
I MEAN, THEY ARE GETTING RICH,
AND THEY ARE ONES THAT ARE
DECIDING WHO COMES IN AND WHO
DOESN'T INTO AMERICA.
>> YEAH.
THE PROFITS ARE ABSOLUTELY
STAGGERING, WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN WE SEIZE 97 MILLION WORTH
OF DRUGS IN 48 HOURS, THIS THAT
SHOWS YOU HOW BAD IT IS.
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT, IF YOU
COUNT HOW MUCH MIGRANTS ARE
PAYING, IF YOU'RE FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA, YOU'RE PAYING $6,000 TO
GET INTO THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU'RE COMING FROM CHINA, IF
YOU'RE COMING FROM COUNTRIES
THAT ARE NOT CONTINGENT TO OUR
CONTINENT, THEN YOU'RE PAYING
UPWARDS OF $35,000.
THESE CARTELS, THE PROFITS ARE
STAGGERING.
AND IT'S ALL BASED UPON OUR
POLICIES.
WE ARE MAKING THEM RICH,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THE BEST
FRIEND TO THESE CARTELS.
>> AND, MARIA --
MARIA: GO AHEAD, GOVERNOR.
>> SOMETHING THAT BRANDON
MENTION END, $6,000 UP TO
30,000.
WHERE ARE THESE POOR PEOPLE
GETTING THE MONEY?
THEY SCRABBLE TOGETHER A LITTLE
BIT OF MONEY, BUT THEY BECOME A
NEW SLAVE POPULATION.
THEY COME TO AMERICA AND THEY
SEND THEIR MONEY BACK TO
WHATEVER COUNTRY THEY COME FROM,
PARTICULARLY IN CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA.
IF THEY DON'T, THEIR FAMILIES
ARE AT RUSK.
SO THESE PEOPLE COMING HERE WILL
BE INDENTURED SERVANTS TO THE
CARTELS FOREVER.
AND ALSO YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND,
MARIA, THAT SOMETHING THAT
BRANDON JUST SAID, THEY'RE LYING
TO US.
ST ONE THING WHEN GOVERNMENT
LIES, BUT IT'S THE ANOTHER THING
WHEN THEY KNOW THEY'RE LYING,
THEY KNOW WE KNOW THEY'RE LYING
AND THEY DON'T CARE.
THAT'S A DANGEROUS GOVERNMENT,
INDEED.
THEY KNOW THEY'RE LYING, PEOPLE
CAN SEE IT FOR THEMSELVES.
MARIA: YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT THE
CHANGE THAT HAS OCCURRED
THROUGHOUT TEXAS, THROUGHOUT
ARIZONA.
I KNOW THAT THESE TRUCKS GET TO
BIG CITIES LIKE NEW YORK --
THESE DRUGS GET TO BIG CITIES
LIKE NEW YORK WITHIN 48 HOURS.
BUT, DAN PATRICK, WHAT CAN YOU
TELL THE US ABOUT HOW TEXAS HAS
CHANGED AND THEN, BRANDON, TELL
US ABOUT ARIZONA.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING ON THE
GROUND HOW THIS IS IMPACTING OUR
CITIES?
>> SURE.
FROM AN ELECTORAL STANDPOINT,
IT'S TURNING THE VALLEY THAT WAS
ALL DEMOCRAT INTO A REPUBLICAN
AREA, NUMBER ONE, POLITICALLY.
MOST OF THOSE FOLKS DOWN THERE
WERE DEMOCRATS NOT LONG AGO.
IT'S A DEMOCRAT MAYOR IN EL PASO
THAT DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
SECONDLY, MARIA, THE PRESIDENT
WILL NEVER ANSWER THIS QUESTION,
WHERE DO THESE PEOPLE GO, WHAT
DO THEY DO?
THEY DON'T HAVE CITIZENSHIP NOW,
SO THEY CAN'T LEGALLY GET A JOB.
HOW DO THE KIDS GET TO SCHOOL?
DO YOU PUT A 15-YEAR-OLD INTO
FOURTH GRADE IN AN AMERICAN
SCHOOL?
THEY CAN'T DO THAT.
THEY CROP OUT -- DROP OUT
QUICKLY, SO HOW DO THEY MAKE A
LIVING?
WHERE DO THESE PEOPLE EVEN GO
DURING HIS 4 OR 8 YEARS, HEAVEN
FORBID HE GET 4 MORE?
THEY'RE A BLIGHT ON SOCIETY.
THEY'RE NOT A PLUS FOR OUR
SOCIETY WHICH IMMIGRANTS COMING
HERE TALK ABOUT SHOULD BE.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY
DON'T CARE.
THIS IS A COLD-HEARTED
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THOSE
PEOPLE COMING HERE, WOMEN WHO
GET RAPED, THE CHILDREN INTO SEX
TRAFFICKING, AND THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE AMERICAN POPULATION,
AND THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT TEXAS,
WHICH I CARE ABOUT.
AND QUICKLY, I HEARD A DEMOCRAT
SAY WE'RE GOING TO PUT 4 BILLION
TO WORK ON BORDER SECURITY.
WE SPEND $4 BILLION A YEAR
OURSELVES IN TEXAS.
SO THEIR $4 BILLION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS A JOKE.
WE NEED, AND BRANDON KNOWS, THIS
IS GOING TO THE TAKE A MASSIVE
EFFORT OF MONEY AND MANPOWER.
WE CAN DO IT WITH NEW LEADERSHIP
IN '24 AND, HOPEFULLY, THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS CAN SLOW
DOWN THIS PRESIDENT.
BUT HE'S DETERMINED TO UNDERMINE
THIS COUNTRY.
>> I AM SO GRATEFUL THAT I'M NOT
A GOVERNOR OR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR IN TEXAS OR IN ARIZONA
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT THEY HAVE TO BE DEALING
WITH IS ABSOLUTELY MONSTROUS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
ENTIRE SOUTHWEST BORDER, THE
CARTELS OPERATE DIFFERENTLY
DEPENDING UPON WHERE THEY'RE AT.
THE GULF CARTEL, THEY OPERATE IN
HIGHER NUMBERS, LOWER COST.
THAT'S WHY EVERYBODY'S CROSSING
ILLEGALLY ARE GIVING THEMSELVES
UP.
TEXAS, THEY HAVE TO BEAR THE
BRUNT OF ALL OF THAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT ARIZONA, YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THE SINALOA CARTEL.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO EVADE APPREHENSION.
THEY'RE CROSSING ILLEGALLY, AND
THEY'RE IN CAMOUFLAGE.
THEY'RE NOT JUST GIVING UP,
THEY'RE TRYING TO EVADE.
MARIA: WOW.
>> AND HEN ON TOP OF IT, LOOK AT
WHAT TEXAS IS DEALING WITH.
MARIA, YOU'VE BEEN DOWN TO THE
BOARD OR.
I'M SURE THAT WHEN YOU WENT DOWN
THERE YOU DEVELOPED IDEAS ON
WHAT WE COULD DO TO SECURE IT,
YET WE DON'T HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT'S WILLING TO GO DOWN TO THE
BORDER TO SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT'S
GOING ON TO TRY TO DEVELOP SOME
IDEAS.
MARIA: JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
TEXAS LIEUTENANT THE GOVERNOR
DAN PATRICK, NATIONAL BORDER
PATROL COUNCIL PRESIDENT BRANDON
JUDD.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP --
>> THANK YOU.